you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's program
the un says country's current plans to
cut emissions won't stop global warming
and predicts temperatures will rise by
at least 2.7 degrees this century
a row erupts between mps and peers over
measures to stop water companies pumping
raw sewage into waterways
and confused over climate change a new
poll finds the public distrusting of
politicians and put off by conflicting
information
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions the un has issued a start
warning that world leaders aren't doing
enough to cut carbon emissions to combat
global warming ahead of the global
climate summit in glasgow next week its
annual emissions gap report says current
commitments by countries to reduce
emissions fall far short of what is
needed to keep the world's temperature
to an increase of no more than 1.5
degrees above pre-industrial levels
the report finds that new and updated
national climate action plans only
reduce greenhouse gas emissions by 7.5
percent in 2030 a 55 reduction is needed
to meet the 1.5 degree target agreed in
paris in 2015.
the current promises which have been
made put the world on track for a
temperature rise of at least 2.7 degrees
this century while net zero commitments
could reduce this increase to 2.2
degrees our science and technology
editor tom clark has more
u.n secretary general calling this a
thundering wake-up call i mean it's hard
to think of how many more wake-up calls
the world really needs when it comes to
climate change but looking at the
s shortfall in emissions cuts that this
report lays starkly bare there's really
hardly any other phrase you can think of
to describe it we do have an enormous
challenge ahead of us
and every country in the world has got
to work a lot harder
even here in the uk we're one of the
we've put one forward one of the leading
uh net zero pledges to do that by 2050
and we put a plan in place for how to do
it but it's important let's not forget
that we're still heavily reliant on
fossil fuels here in the uk this
gas-fired power station is still
essential for keeping our lights on at
times when the wind isn't blowing or
there isn't very much nuclear power on
the grid our net zero strategy is going
to be fraught with challenges but for
some countries there isn't really very
much of a plan at all and that's what
the un is trying to really put out there
ahead of the glasgow summit world
leaders you need to show more ambition
we need to go further
but it's important to point out also the
unet report is
erring on the pessimistic side it's only
looking about what national governments
have put forward there's a lot of
diplomacy and jostling that goes on
ahead of a climate summit
what's actually going on the real
economy you could argue as a slightly
rosier picture take australia for
example its six states together have put
forward a more ambitious plan for
cutting carbon than the australian
national government have managed to do
that's repeated in other places around
the world lots of businesses going for
net zero targets that aren't uh
including this unet report and also the
real economy is now switching away from
fossil fuels to renewable energy the
costs of those are coming down we're
switching to electric cars and other
forms of heating our homes and cooling
that are more sustainable again not
featured in that report it's a stark and
very worrying concerning warning ahead
of the the climate summit in glasgow but
it's certainly on the more pessimistic
side of what we can expect to see
the government has defended itself
against claims it's not doing enough to
stop sewage ending up in the country's
waterways
mps voted against an amendment to the
environment bill which would have put a
legal duty on water companies to reduce
raw sewage discharges into rivers which
happened more than four hundred thousand
times last year according to the
environment agency but downing street
said the current proposal is uncosted
and a lot is already being done to
tackle the issue skies helenan smith has
more
there's a real sense of fury gathering
ahead of steam over this issue
particularly in places like this i'm in
salt dean on the south coast one of the
places that over the last few weeks has
had sewage released into the ocean there
it's just a few miles up uh from seaford
which is one of the places one of the
eight places along the south coast where
southern water have said that they've
actually had a wastewater release in the
last 24 hours and locals who swim here
who kites are here say that they often
notice a lot of the really filthy uh
stuff that gets released into the water
a swimmer said sometimes you'll see
sanitary products floating around things
like that so a real sense of anger
here locally it's worth noting on this
issue that is actually nothing new about
releasing wastewater uh into the seas it
happens because of the old vestiges of
our old victorian sewage system where
rainwater and wastewater aren't dealt
with separately so when there's a lot of
wet weather or too much water in the
system they both have to be released
together but the reason this is uh such
a matter of attention right now is
because there was a chance according to
campaigners for things to improve there
was an amendment tabled to the
environment bill which would make it
much much more difficult for water
companies to do this and that amendment
was rejected and that's caused this huge
outpouring of rage on social media lots
of constituents tagging their local mp
if their local mp voted against this
issue so pressure really mounting on the
government and it's melting in
particular because cop starts next week
this is the moment where they're really
trying to burnish uh their green
cadentials worth saying that those mps
and southern water and other water
companies say the reason this is so
complicated for them is because it would
cost hundreds of billions to update that
sewage system a very very expensive
thing to do some really start wanting to
have a conversation about how that's
funded but at this time of the rising
cost of living it just hasn't really
played out to be a priority but
certainly for people here absolutely
furious and they say it should be a
human right for people to swim in clean
seas here
a lack of trust in politicians and the
media along with too many conflicting
opinions are leaving the public confused
about climate change while most people
are concerned about the issue and
willing to make changes many don't know
who or what to believe our climate
change correspondent hannah thomas peter
is here with me hannah the information
is coming thick and fast so are the
warnings but are they getting through
well that could be a real problem
according to this poll which was
conducted by yougov and the university
of cambridge in collaboration with the
conversation website and shared
exclusively with sky news it found that
67 of people don't trust politicians to
tell them the truth about climate change
54 percent don't trust journalists and
71 percent don't trust online
influencers there are high levels of
trust in academics though with 67
percent of consumers trusting them to be
truthful this was closely followed by
the way with high levels of trust in
friends and family too
the poll also revealed that people are
finding climate change information
difficult to understand over a quarter
found climate change content on social
media confusing nearly two-thirds say
there are too many conflicting opinions
and over a third of consumers found
general media coverage problematic too
with 39 declaring it too abstract and
too focused on the future rather than
the here and now this is what sander van
der linden professor of social
psychology from cambridge university had
to say about the potential impact of all
of this
when people lose trust in mainstream
media sources this can erode uh you know
informed public discourse people can
turn to alternative sources for uh for
information about climate change which
you know may not always be uh be helpful
um and it can generate this leads to a
skewed information diet i think we
generally you know have a bit of a trust
problem and i think the way to fix that
is to you know get better at
communicating facts about climate change
and making sure that misinformation
doesn't spread why does all of this
matter so much right now well we are
just days away from that crucial u.n
climate summit that's going to be held
in glasgow cop26 and trust is the
currency at the very heart of that
summit politicians need the public to
trust in them and believe in the
solutions that they're going to be
agreeing on hannah thank you
in some of today's other climate news
two climate activists shut down
queensland's largest coal port after
locking themselves to a coal conveyor
belt the prime minister scott morrison
has announced australia will reach net
zero by 2050 but one activist julia
lamont says the country's plans are
lagging behind in a shameful way
this is a prime minister whose country
is burning in the last bushfire season
and he's holidaying in hawaii with the
beer while his country burns and says
that he can't even hold a hose so you
know we have absolutely no leadership
and it's shameful i don't know if it's
if it's too much to say that we need
carbon tax tariffs um
and and trade sanctions but he really
needs to get a sort of a realistic and
and imp and a climate policy that he can
implement now because we're lagging
behind in a shameful way
now the green finance summit in paris
has been disrupted by activists members
of the protest group lizami de la terre
accused the french president of failing
to tackle investment in fossil fuels
macron's government says it is committed
to going carbon neutral by 2050 but a
court found france failed to respect its
own carbon budget earlier this month
china will take action to reduce waste
promote renewables and reform its
electricity network as part of its plan
to bring carbon emissions to a peak
before 2030. the new action plan repeats
china's targets to build more hydropower
and nuclear plants and develop natural
gas resources our correspondent tom
cheshire has more
a lot of people have been hoping for
something big and new from china head of
cop 26 this isn't that what this is is
the detail of how they're going to meet
their existing emissions plan that
president xi jinping announced last year
to be carbon neutral by 2016 but
specifically for this one to peak
emissions by 2030. and it is a bit of a
mixed bag even then on one hand um you
have got what looks like a pretty
comprehensive document a lot of work has
gone into that this touches nearly every
aspect of the chinese economy so it's
perhaps being entrenched in the
bureaucracy and that means there's less
of a chance of backsliding on these
stated goals but on the other hand
you've got some pretty conservative
language when it comes to peaking
emissions they talk about doing it
rationally and maintaining energy
security as well and then when it comes
to coal things are a bit more worrying
too coal is of course the most polluting
fossil fuel and china burns more of it
than the rest of the world combined it
said it will peak emissions by 2025 but
it says it will rationally control the
growth until then so there is still
going to be growth and then only
gradually reduce it afterwards so in
terms of how long that peak would be for
the chinese use of coal people hoping it
would drop off quickly it doesn't seem
like that's going to be the case it's
going to have a long tail and that is
obviously bad news for the environment
to stay with us coming up after the
break we'll be discussing that warning
from the un that we're in danger of
seeing a global temperature increase of
2.7 this century i'll be joined by the
economist vicki price and professor of
global change science at ucl and the
university of leeds simon lewis
did you know if more of us walked rolled
bikes and scooted to school we would
make a big difference to the air
pollution around our school yeah like us
wednesday will start mild windy and dry
for many but ireland northern ireland
southern scotland and cumbria will see
rain heavy on the hills
there'll be little change through the
morning but western parts of ireland
should dry up the best of the sunshine
will be across northern scotland it'll
stay very mild and windy
during the afternoon the rain will
largely clear into northwest england and
northwest wales
the unsettled conditions mean air
pollution levels are expected to remain
low with the levels between 1 and 3 on
the daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with the
economist vicki price and professor of
global change science at ucl and the
university of leeds simon lewis
current climate change pledges from
world leaders will not be enough to keep
global temperature targets according to
a new report from the united nations the
organization's secretary general has
warned world leaders that the era of
promises must end saying closing the
emissions gap must start in glasgow as
world leaders come under even more
pressure just a few days before cop 26
can the summit be a success
vicki it has been described as a
thundering wake up call today that the
world is heading towards climate
catastrophe will world leaders pay
attention ahead of that summit
well they will and i think we've been
prepared for it i mean obviously there
was some hint that the the report was
going to suggest pretty bad news in
terms of what has been achieved so far
and what the various pledges will be
achieving
and of course it's a wake-up call and
boris johnson himself has been telling
everyone not to expect perhaps too much
because
that gap is enormous in the sense of
what needs to be done extra if we are to
get even near
achieving uh the 1.5 it looks like on
current projections if we believe the
the figures are coming out now that
we're going to be way above that
and what needs to happen
is that efforts should be concentrated
very much on what goes on between now
and 2030 and what i find quite
surprising actually
is uh that despite the fact that both
the uk of course and the eu seem to have
quite ambitious plans that they have put
together which will be reducing
uh carbon emissions very significantly
from 1990 levels um with the eu of
course pledging 55 percent the the uk
pledging even higher figures by 2030 to
2035 um obviously the big emitters the
us china and of course up to a point
also india don't look like they're doing
enough i'm guessing that is why it looks
so bad in terms of what the pledges are
telling us
simon the warning came that if there's
no meaningful change we will have lost
forever the chance of achieving 1.5
celsius and only 2.7 degree rises in
temperatures this century in practical
terms what would that mean what would it
look like
it's a world we really don't want to
find out about uh
large areas of the earth would have
unlivable heat
at uh parts of the year
we would see the kind of climate impacts
we saw last summer of massive heat waves
in canada
of floods washing houses into
the
rivers in germany and people up to their
necks in water on the subway system in
china happening with great frequency and
for me i think it's very hard to see how
agriculture globally can adapt to that
kind of level
of change uh and keep food supplies
going for what will at that point be uh
eight or nine billion people on earth it
would be a real catastrophe and world
leaders um
in in these next two weeks really need
to um
push hard to have practical policies to
reduce emissions in the short term
and simon we heard that warning from the
prime minister yesterday that that he's
really worried
we've had saudi arabia's pledges we've
had australia today but the problem has
been highlighted that many of those net
zero goals remain vague we haven't got
the details of them and much of the
heavy lifting is pushed to after
2030 is anything in glasgow going to
change that
well i do think that these net zero
pledges are important because they bring
climate action
two decades earlier and that means that
we then start talking about what is
going to happen in the 2020s and what to
watch out for at this summit is the
first two days when more than 120 world
leaders will be in glasgow making
pledges and making announcements and
that's the time to look for potentially
big announcements about what might
happen over the next decade
vicki and simon stay with us because
another report released today shed new
light on our online data habits in
particular storing photos it's claimed
that unwanted digital photos produce the
same amount of carbon emissions as more
than a hundred thousand return flights
from london to australia so do we all
need to take more responsibility for
tackling the climate crisis
vicky
we think about what we do at home don't
we we think about the way in which we
use energy we think about the cars that
we drive we think about the things that
we eat for example i've never even
considered
my phone and the photographs that i take
as being a factor here
well absolutely and i have to say when i
read the report i immediately looked at
all my photographs well i didn't look at
them all because of course there are so
many
i like everyone else is keeping rather a
lot of data on our phones and computers
that perhaps we don't need to do um but
the knowledge that um
platforms like
whether it's facebook google
um for example
are in fact making us all and they
themselves consume an awful lot of
energy it's been around for some time
and
the figures are such that suggest that
in fact the energy consumed through all
our uses if you like is something
equivalent to
airline emissions
global airline emissions at present
which is pretty large that's about three
to four percent
of global emissions and of course there
is a huge increase in the use and
although we've read about this of course
we individually didn't think that just
googling something uh a few times also
of course you know emits
at the end of the day a lot of co2 um
what of our worry about is that this
report says what we as individuals
should do but obviously policymakers
should know that this is happening the
data has been out there for some time
and we know that it's going to be even
bigger in the future i mean the question
now with post covet and us all using a
lot of social media and other ways in
terms of communicating that is supposed
to be good for the environment i think
something needs to give um so we can't
just be living in this ignorance or at
least most people not realizing that
what they're doing is also contributing
to worsening the environment and
i don't know and i haven't quite thought
about what the implications of this can
be whether indeed uh you know all those
platforms can be more energy efficient
but obviously they need to okay and
simon i did the same as vicky i looked
immediately when i read this at the
number of photos on my phone i don't
even want to admit it
um
vicky talked about the responsibility of
individuals is there something we can
all do to clean up our habits and what
about the companies themselves
well i looked at this report as a
conscientious scientist and looked at
the calculations behind it and what
they're saying is that all of this
social media and internet activity is
about 0.2 percent
of our emissions over the whole year so
it's very very small and we need to keep
in mind the big picture here if we get
our electricity system down to zero
emissions through renewables then we can
then take as many photographs as we like
vicki simon thanks to both of you
well that is everything from us for
today joining us on tomorrow's show is
greenpeace uk's head of climate kate
blagojevich and organic farmer and
deputy president of the national farmers
union stuart roberts
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time